[Music]
life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David valueing giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to ha run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one become homie what was that Tom
that's timeing homie oh wow okay that's
great well today home team gang we got a
lot of stories that we haven't covered
due to guests that we've been having I
said last minute why don't we do a home
team and we're doing it an hour
typically before we do the podcast so
California it's 5:00 a.m. many people
are probably not even awake yet for this
podcast but those of you that are with
us fantastic let's get right into it a
lot going on
economy um 10e treasury yield hits 4.8%
a 16-year high banks are bracing for a
recession as treasury yield
surge mortgage rate races towards 8%
after hitting a high not seen since late
2000 and Thomas saying they're about to
increase the uh uh possibly the rates
again and if they do the rest of the
year is going to be very very
interesting many will have to brace for
impact there's a Jabs report that came
in September's Jabs report there's a lot
lot of things in it a couple strikes
going on people that this was the year
of Investigation the year of strikes
gang wait till you hear the Wrecking
breaking uh uh strike that's taking
place right now and then we'll go into
what Putin's doing Putin says Russia has
tested Next Generation nuclear weapon
and they said Russia's mission is to
create the new world not be part of the
new world order but to create the new
world GOP holds the biggest lead on
economy since 1991 wait till you see
what happened to Starbucks in San
Francisco uh very interesting that it
coincides with what happened with Nancy
Pelosi weird Jamie Diamond says AI could
bring not 4 day work week but he was
aggressive he said three and 1 half day
work week wow three and a half day work
week is what he's saying it's coming
here soon and then outside of that
American apocalypse 71% of Americans
don't believe the US government uh uh is
able to prevent doomsday Trevor Bower's
accuser Lindsey Hall opens up on text
and video claims and even Trevor Bower
finally shows video and it's done done
but they stole two years of his
life and I would say probably $100
million of this guy's life on what they
did and it's permanent that story is
going to stick around for a while World
economic Forum advisor says the coming
Water Crisis will force people to accept
climate mandates and America's
non-religious groups growing outside of
that the last story I'll tell you here
that we'll get into which is very
annoying adults shouting by the way this
is a CNN story adult adults check this
out Vinnie adults shouting at children
can be as harmful to a child's
development as sexual or physical abuse
let me read this to you one more time
folks it sounds I thought you're joking
adults shouting at children can be as
harmful to a child's development as
sexual or physical abuse so we again
just absolutely Insanity when you're
hearing a story like that but uh uh why
don't we do this why don't we go into a
story and then we'll go to our sponsor
and then we'll get into the podcast so
strike Tom why don't you lead the way
tell us what's going on with these
strikes so we've been talking about the
Hollywood strike and we've been talking
about the UAW strike but in the last 48
hours the largest strike in US history
happened as the healthc care workers
walked out oh great this is so what is
happening is could it be that in the
mind of the worker the unionized worker
and unions remember in uh private unions
maybe private companies we're not
talking about teachers unions are
government unions those are public
unions these private unions people are
looking around and saying wow you know
stock market's up uh you know look at
the amount that CEOs make and everything
uh the economy seems to pop back after
coid and inflation's hurting me I want
to be paid more and so how do unionize
people do it they negotiate and when
that doesn't work to their liking of big
jumps they go on strike and so all the
talk about Hollywood over the last 2 and
a half months all the talk about the UAW
and the auto workers what's happening to
potentially the price and availability
of cars as workers aren't working yet 48
hours last 48 hours the largest strike
in US history happened healthcare
workers wow how many is that 75,000 went
out on day one I saw that and the raise
they're asking for is what what's the
raise they're asking for it's it's it's
the standard 20 to 40% and then they're
trying to find out where that soft
Landing in the negotiation is going to
be so how different is this one than the
other strikes that are taking place I
don't think it's very different at all
it's like they're they are trying to
make up for lost time and they're all
getting pinched by inflation so the
argument that they're making is one is
economic and saying and I can't even
afford to buy eggs you know but on the
other side is hey we haven't had cost of
living increases that's an argument in a
beef with the employer well our cost of
living increase is having kept pace with
inflation well if Cola was keeping Pace
with inflation last year's Cola would
have been 16 and a half% Tom after two
years how much of this we we've seen the
Hollywood writers strike we've seen the
actor strike we've seen the United Auto
Workers now we're seeing Healthcare this
is like breaking news right how much of
this is tied to inflation cost of living
increases how much of it is tied to AI
especially in the writer strike make
some sense of the common threat of
what's actually happening with all these
strikes because I can't remember a time
where it's strike strike we've seen the
teacher Union do this every once in a
while make sense of this for us Tom so
the AI you bring up a really great point
is what there's a lot of factors in here
and so Adam I think the AI is not as
prevalent in these Union and
Manufacturing and jobs as as I don't
think AI hits those jobs I don't think
AI hits the worker on the assembly line
the use of Robotics does but that's not
AI What's Happening Here is these people
are regular citizens nieces nephews
Aunts Uncles of everybody in this room
they are out there and they have felt
the effects of now three years of
inflation which I added up to 6 half% on
core 24% if you add in energy and things
like that so they're feeling that effect
that's not the fault of the employer but
the colas the cost of living increases
2% 3% 2% that were in the last Union
contract haven't kept up with that so
they're like hey look at the stock
market look at corporate profits look at
what the CEO made you know what look
what happened with inflation I can't
afford to buy eggs so they're going out
on strike part of it is a la
in in normal Cola and the other half of
it man they're trying to make ends meet
and they have one employer but they're
armed with the Union contract and so
they're striking so you're saying it's
not necessarily the fault of the
employer we get that right especially
big corporations at the same time
profits have been up what about regular
businesses out there because most people
here that listening aren't running
Fortune 500 companies they're running
small businesses 100 employees if not
less or more how is it affecting those
types of companies as well to answer
your first question question I think
it's 60/40 60% the economy and 40% the
company cuz remember these are union
contracts and you know they're
dissatisfied with the Union contract the
minute they sign it right from that
moment the average union worker is
dissatisfied with the contract because
there's all the stuff we didn't get in
the contract well we'll wait three years
and next time we'll go get them and I
think it's 40% the economy so I think
that there was a simmering frustration
and the inflation over three years on
Biden NX boom put a match on that on
that I I also that drive straw I think
there' be an opport opportunistic what
is this article saying five things to
know about the strike and it go a little
lower so uh uh because if you're a
patient Pat like what like how's going
people or no you know you know I mean
Tom I think I know where you're going
Pat I agree with that word they're
seeing everybody else St yeah I think
it's purely it's kind of like you know
all the houses in your community sell
for two times what you bought two years
ago and people are going to be like dude
I'm selling I'm selling I'm selling I'm
selling I'm selling let's Capital let's
cash in on strikes right now so five
things you need to know workers are
mainly striking in California Colorado
Oregon you can still see doctor during
the strike lap test may take longer your
surgery may be rescheduled or postponed
oh wow inconvenient if it's a triple
bypass your prescription may take longer
to get so 75,000 I looked at it right
now they're asking for a 25% raise is
what they're asking for Kaiser came back
and Kaiser offered them a uh 12 and a
half to 16% range to 10,000 employees
but the union came back and said no we
want more in a season like this by the
way it partly partially when you looking
at this
is why is this happening you say the
economy right we talked about this a
couple weeks ago about a mortgage
payment do we talk about what a mortgage
payment would be on a
$500,000 yeah yes you did you did the
math for everybody how it doubled did
did we do that on the podcast or was it
on did on the
uh after La when we were in La when you
were on Dave Ruben and the oh I did it
on Reuben or I did it on this you did it
on Reuben okay so then let me do this
let me go to the story so check this out
so mortgage rate races towards 8% after
hitting a high not seen since late 2000
okay this is a CNBC story that we're
talking about this is so here here's
what it looks like Rob get the mortgage
calculator from Google up yeah that
would be perfect so the the average rate
for 30-year fixed mortgage rate search
to
7.72 the highest since the end of 2000
driven by Rising yields on a 10year
treasury which has been climbing due to
strong economic data mortgage rates
which had briefly dropped to around 6%
at the beginning of the year have been
steadily rising over the summer impact
in home sales despite the strong demand
there's a possibility that rates may
exceed 8% the higher mortgage rates have
adversely affected housing affordability
and a new and ex existing home sale
markets causing home builder sentiment
to decline for example a borrower
purchasing a $400,000 house with a %
down payment on a 30-year fix face a
mortgage payment roughly 930 higher
compared to a 3% rate during the height
of Co pandemic so check this out pull up
the co uh mortgage calculator if you can
all right let's say you do
$500,000 okay is the loan 30 are fixed
and take that to 8% okay take that to
8% okay so the payment is what 3669 just
write that down 3700
3669 now roommates the only thing I want
you to change is just change that 8% to
3% M which was what it was 18 months ago
21108 okay so 2118 almost, 1500 you're
talking about,
1551 more so do
1551 divided by 21108 what's
1551 ID 21108 1551 ID 21108 is it's a 7
24% increase on mortgage payments so the
now Rob if we do this take the
2108 just pull up a regular calculator
pull up a regular calculator and divide
the 21108 put 2,108 divided
by
36 36 equals that's what the bank is
going to want to see for your income
time 12 what okay no no hang on so so
the the the bank is going to want your
monthly income to be 5855 do it now
times 12 to see what the annual would be
okay equals what so they want a $70,000
your income to qualify for a $500,000
loan 18 months ago now oh wow go clear
the whole thing up real quick why' you
do 36 that's the debt to income gotcha
that's what you need to be making
explain that for a second your bank is
revaluating you right for people
listening y so the bank is looking at
you saying can this guy afford to buy
this house how much money do you make
per month so they'll take the mortgage
payment and divide it time you know
typical number is going to be36 and you
get that number to know this is what you
need to make to be able to afford to buy
the house so now watch this go to the
3669 so same house same area 18 months
different rates are 8% now divided times
divided by
36 now the bank wants you to make
10,911 time 12 so so so over 100 Grand a
year you're saying yeah wait guys they
want your income how about
be
$122,000 to qualify for the same house
so then the question so so then you ask
the question for the strikes and you say
okay why are they striking maybe because
they can't afford to buy the house so
byonics guess what more he talks about
biomics it's the worst thing he's doing
for himself to moris Sama byonics and
and outside of this you know what's the
first default that's shown right now you
know what is the first default cuz right
now commercial uh real estate well we're
seeing on a lower level so you got let's
C cize the defaults we have car payments
under car payments we have good credit
car payments and we have D paper which
is subprime car payments then on
mortgage you have what regular people
that got mortgages that have good credit
then you have subprime then you have
commercial real estate is what regular
people that got good you know commercial
some of them that did hardcore financing
you have school loans okay you know what
is the first thing right now that's
defaulting right now is subprime car
payments is up skyrocketing which is
core workers that have a reasonable
amount of debt and they're probably
paying 15% if less more whatever it is
yeah so because these guys credit is not
750 their credit score is a 650 620 and
they're trying to get car financing you
ever gone to a car try to dealership to
get a car financing with back credit
your payment is 30% higher 20% higher
that guy a if you're in that financial
situation probably don't understand
interest rates for all that matter but
when you walk into the car lot they're
like how much does your monthly payment
need to be all right yeah I can afford
350 bucks they don't like don't look
over here that you're paying 18% and
that's how payment based that's how car
companies oh you know you're absolutely
that's how they make their money don't
look here let's describe one of those
subprime workers Pat's talking about how
about this a nurse at Kaiser Permanente
making 65 Grand a year 7 years out of
school still with school loans she is a
subprime borrower and she is is
currently in a pickup line yeah and and
that so that is the reason why I believe
a lot of these strikes are taking place
because the economy is destroying the
average guy today yeah it is destroying
the average guy you know who else is
starting a default right now who else is
starting a default right now by the way
you know weor at one point was a47
billion a company weor you've heard of
we work yeah they just defaulted on a
payment Rob type in rework default
payment uh I think it's a $95 million
payment they just defaulted on zoom in a
little bit $95 million payment they just
defaulted on what so shared office bace
rental company wew work said it wouldn't
be making interest payments on about $95
million due Monday and its shares fell
at an all-time low weor said it would
use its 30-day grace period for the debt
payments to hold discussions with
certain stakeholders and to enhance its
liquidity you miss on a $95 million
payment now you may say dude Pat that's
a lot of money you were valued at $47
billion so you know what this shows can
you can you type in we work highest
valuation we work highest valuation I
think it's 4647 billion $47 billion I
was right so you're a $47 billion they
get they get they get look at this year
in 2017 soft bank group made the first
of its total $8.5 billion do investment
in the company wow 95 million is what
1.1 billion you can't make a payment
like that so now you got sub guys hang
on divide 1.1 billion by 36 how much
does that company have to you divide you
divide you that's a good point by the
way you divide you you you look at
default payments on Commercial Real
Estate okay okay Pro so we work as the
bigger commercial because that's what
they do they rent the office space you
know then you default on subprime you
know what HD in 08 that destroy the
economy mortgage payments people started
defaulting gone we haven't felt that yet
that's why this is a very different and
the reason why default isn't hitting why
isn't default hitting cuz people got low
interest rates right that's what I was
going to say yeah they got low interest
rates back in the ' 08 we all remember
Nina right no income no assets those are
the good old days you know stripper
making 100 Grand cash bought just three
houses congratulations we saw that
remember the The Big Short the with
Steve Carol you have three houses and a
condo and a condo yeah doing their thing
so anac cond what' you say
anac go anaco I thought for a second you
were seeing go want to touch you can you
Just Dance I know you're a big Nicki
Minaj fan I know she's a huge fan of the
case studies you do I know that she
cites you all the time respect um ever
met I I would like to to know the the
mortgages that are defaulting now
percentage of how many are defaulting
from the good old days you know 3% or
less versus people that got a mortgage
in the last let's say 24 months since
mortgages have skyrocketed where that
comes in you're like all right I just
really wanted to buy a house I missed
the I missed the boat I could have got
3% a year or two ago now I'm at 6.5%
boom default I got laid off my job
unemployed pick it line what have you
that would be an interesting case study
if you see that would be to see which
one is default then somebody in that
space has to break it down and see where
these defaults are going to be because
they're not here yet so a lot of real
estate and mortgage guys are saying well
you know you guys called the Doomsday
all this stuff it's not here they're
right it's not here yet because people
are not selling their houses cuz they
don't want to lose that 3% interest you
know what I'm thinking about to you know
that like when you don't make a payment
not you I'm just saying a general on
your credit card they call the creditors
they call you what is that 95 million
phone call like like hey yeah we work
yeah when are you what do you guys do
and then Pat what's the what's the thing
that we showed the five ways is
affecting the patients Rob one of them
was you could still see your doctor
where on the picket line you're going
have to show up and be like
yo do it's Vinnie look I have a rash and
he's like just get the hell off the
street well you know speaking of that
$95 temperature and blood pressure sure
who we talked about what was going on in
China not everr but a company bigger
than evergr in China the commercial real
estate developer what was the name of
that company do you recall whatever
they're a huge massive real estate
company they they had to make a $25
million payment whatever the number was
yeah but they're valued at100 billion
some astronomical number but they didn't
make the payment so not that our Mar our
audience is concerned of what's going on
in Chinese real estate but here it is
right here Country Garden makes $22
million payment with 15 billion more to
go that's insane wow so again this is a
sign of what's to come by the way before
we get to the next story let's go to our
sponsors Masterworks here's Masterworks
you ever seen a movie Big Short you know
the guy Michael bur who said the
Market's going to crash nobody believed
him well Michael bur just recently bet
$1.6 billion against the market he took
people's money $1.6 billion and he said
the Market's about to go down that's
what he did the last time he got it
right he's doing it again on top of that
Jerome Powell about about interest rates
is I'm still not comfortable with what's
going on with inflation which means they
may raise the rates again proceeding
carefully is the word they're using so
what's happen at a time like this
alternative assets is one of the things
a lot of people are looking at this is
why we decided to work with Masterworks
and they're our sponsor today
Masterworks they've done 16 sales so far
with all 16 returning to profit and just
weeks ago they sold a Sicily Brown piece
for a 77% annualized return obviously
that's not all of them that's just one
they just had a few weeks ago so you may
be watching and saying you know I like
but I can't afford Banky I can't afford
Warhol I can't afford basat but I would
like to own a piece of it or fractions
of it that's exactly what Masterworks
does that's why over 800,000 people have
already registered with Masterworks and
if you're part of the pbd podcast you
watch it you have now the ability to
skip that waiting list that everybody
has now if you want to learn more about
Masterworks go to
masterworks.io so if we go to page
15 uh uh page 15 treasury bonds uh this
is another issue here that some are very
worried about 10-year treasury yields
4.8% a 16-year high this is a CNBC story
this the highest level since 2007
hitting 4.8% while the third-year uh
treasury yield searched to 4.92 four
these uh yields have implications for
mortgage rates and investment sentiment
the increase in yields comes as a jab
opening and labor turnover survey
indicates a tight labor market giving
the Federal Reserve reason to continue
raising rates Bingo that's not what
realtor Realtors want to hear fed
officials
have deferring views on the need for
further rate hikes but most agree that
rates will remain elevated for a
considerable period Market uncertainty
surrounds the timing of rate hikes with
two Central Bank policy meetings
scheduled for the remainder of the Year
Tom what does this mean to the average
guy well to the average guy basically
means that rates on everything are going
to be higher longer that's what it means
so the car loans Home Loans credit cards
even if you get good credit if you carry
over you know a month or two you know
that they're going to be higher longer
and it means that businesses are going
to have a tougher time uh expanding when
they're turning to the bond market or
the debt Market to go get debt because
they're going to have to pay for it so
the average person is going to see the
cost of borrowing on basic things like a
car used car you know you uh um give an
example you finance an air conditioning
unit how much is an air conditioning
unit P you've seen them at your house
like 25 30 grand 30 grand for me I
bought like six of them the last the one
what about the one here one of them was
48 Grand
$48,000 yeah so if you let put it in
perspective what if you have a
middle-sized house with two $24,000
units Upstairs Downstairs that's $48,000
people those are things that the average
consumer has to finance when they when
they happen so the rates are going to be
higher longer on um on financing and
it's going to be harder for businesses
to borrow money and expand so uh job
openings are going to be less so the
average person is going to see probably
for the next 24 36 months a very tenuous
economy and ignore the headlines about
high-flying stocks like Nvidia oh wait
which is down 15% in 2 weeks after their
Peak um it's going to be tough for the
average person Adam you also had
thoughts on this you were digging this
this morning as well well so obviously
in the asset world you have stocks and
you have bonds and you have cash and
then you know alternative assets as well
but I think it's important to understand
that obviously the younger you are the
more risk you can take right so you
should be more in equities and stocks
and the older you are you're more in
fixed income and bonds and there sort of
a relationship there as we've seen over
the last couple years with drone pal and
the Feld they they've raisen in interest
rates so Tom correct me if I'm wrong uh
interest rates and bonds have an inverse
relationship right meaning they go sort
of in opposite directions as interest
rates go up bonds go down as Bond as
interest rates go down bonds go up so
the the the market I mean here just look
at this article right here this from
Business Insider the collapse in
treasury bonds now ranks among the worst
Market crashes in history nobody's
talking about the bond market every the
stock market the stock market the stock
market the Dows up the S&P what people
don't sometimes realize is there's an
entire Market called the bond market
that is completely SE from the stock
market and the collapse in treed bounce
now ranks among the worst and crashes in
history as you can see on screen and
there's another Inside Story same day
investors are now having a panic attack
about the bond market so Tom should
young people even worry about something
like this do they have bonds even in
their portfolio or is this something
that if you're the 65 plus Community not
that you're going to be there anytime
soon Tom you're you're holding steady I
get it uh what are older people what
what should my mom be thinking about
right now what should this actually
reminds me of something you said there's
two types of people in this world
there's the people that are trying to
make their first billion and the people
who already have it the people that
trying to make their first billion
aren't necessarily investing in bonds
but the people already have it want to
keep their money in a very secure uh
risk-free asset class but it seems
pretty freaking risky today it it it is
um it used to be that you could go to
treasuries because it's backed by the
you know the confidence of the US
government and whatnot and over the last
two years there is a finance vehicle
that has been big with people over 65
it's been huge the billions that have
gone there have been astronomical and it
is the annuity because the annuity is is
a financial vehicle for people don't
know what annuity is it's like the
opposite of an insurance policy
insurance policy you pay a little bit
along the way and then when you die
there's a big payment that's made to
your to your family your heirs the
beneficiary well a annuity is opposite
you take a lump of money and you give it
to the insurance company and after about
s years they start giving you a monthly
allowance and it's a great way to give
yourself another payment in addition to
any pensions or Social Security you
might have well annuities are also safe
because the they have a guaranteed
interest rate and if the market crashes
your annuity stays Frozen at that number
so your annuity doesn't crash so it's a
very good vehicle for older people so
sorry to get technical but right now
with this going on there is a flight to
Quality and protection and annuities or
cash my I I looked at my mom's um meril
Lynch report and they have her almost
65% M she's she's 82 so they have her
almost 65% cash and she was at 5.375
last month I'm like praise God somebody
at meral Lynch is paying attention and
working with your mom because that's the
right decision and and money market
accounts are paying
5% 5% this is a money if you go back to
' 08 which patch mentioned before with
the recession and lowering of the
interest rates essentially there was
free money for over a decade right what
was the FED fund rate prior to 20 2020
0% well the time the crash the average
uh Mortgage in America was 5.25 the
mortgage rate but I'm saying the the FED
fund rate like it was 0% yeah yeah
moments moments the end of 08 certain
markets like in Europe and Asia where
was actually negative right like minus
1% yep now the FED fund rate is what 5%
the prime rate is closer to 8% so kind
of to Circle back to my point as the
interest rates go up Bond prices fall
okay so let's go to this next story here
Wall Street Journal Wall Street thinks
America's homes are overvalued by the
way New York Post story uh previous day
says us office real estate prices headed
for severe crash investor sales so let
me read The Wall Street Journal one they
kind of go together us singly family
house prices are have continued to rise
despite interest rate hikes reaching a
new high in July while commercial real
estate including Apartments have faced
declines in value institutional
investors who bought numerous single
family homes during the pandemic have
scaled back their purchases due to
Rising debt costs and moderated rent
growth large
landlords purchase only 4% of us homes
in the second quarter down from a peak
of 2.4% in late 2021 some real estate
investment trusts read specializing in
single family homes have slowed their
buying or become net sellers shares of
us single family housing rits Real
Estate Investment Trust trade at a 20%
discount folks that's a 20 so a a $40
million property is 38 $32 million 20%
discount $500,000 house is $ 400,000
that's right a gross asset value
suggesting cautioning among investors
about the future value of home prices
and then New York Post says the
following a survey of investors
indicates that commercial real estate
market in the US is heading for a severe
collaps primarily due to high interest
rates and declining property values
approximately two 2/3 of respondents
believe that the market will only
recover after a crash respondents in the
survey predict different timelines for
when office property the prices will hit
bottom with 44% expecting it to happen
the second half of the next year and 22%
anticipating it'll happen the first 6
months of 2024 only 6% believe prices
will bottom out this year while 29%
think it'll be in 2025 or later factors
contributing to this impendent crisis
include aggressive rates uh by the
Federal Reserve reduced demand for
office space spaces and concerns about
potential defaults on $1 half trillion
in debt maturing by the end of 2025 Tom
this is scary so basically what this is
saying if the if the American
residential homes are is a stock market
so just think of that you don't have to
get deep in the technical let's just say
all residential homes in America is a
stock market and you you know basically
you have your property tax you have the
a house that sold down the street one of
the few houses that did and you can see
the price sold for that is your market
price so there's your average market
price right now today your stock market
is trading 20% below that meaning that
they believe there's a bubble well
what's going to trigger the bubble well
Pat was just reading second half of 24
or into 25 why are they forecasting that
far out I'll tell you why they believe
the FED is going to raise interest rates
one quarter point on October 31st
Halloween to uh November 1st that's when
they have their next meeting and then
hold steady for 6 months getting through
fourth quarter see what Black Friday is
all about see how the consumer spent get
into the beginning of the year where you
know it's usually lackluster in January
and then the consumer picks up they're
forecasting that they will not come to
lower rates and this is the Fed all the
FED Governors talking that they're not
going to make the First Rate lowering
until the end of March end of q1
beginning of Q2 next year so that's the
first time the rate lowers then if the
economy is doing well and there'll be
pressure from the administration to
lower those rates going into the
election owe that and so as that happens
toward the end of 24 now the mortgages
maybe drop under seven to 6 and a
quarter and maybe touch that magic
5.75 people would be willing to sell
sell at what price these folks think the
bubble is going to be a 20% pricing
adjustment so I hope you follow that
little storyline there I tried to keep
it straight 20% the I actually want to
get uh your perspective pbd so we talked
about the inverse relationship between
the interest rates and the bonds and and
and all that fun stuff I'm curious to
know the relationship the correlation
between residential real estate prices
and home prices and the correlation
there what's my point during coid we saw
the exact opposite thing happen it was
talk about supply and demand the rush to
go buy a house during coid was
astronomical everyone wanted to move out
of their apartment and move out of the
city get buy their house mortgage rates
were 3% rush rush rush rush rush major
demand for residential housing but the
exact opposite get me one was get me the
hell out of this office get me out of my
lease I do not want to be here work from
anywhere work from home so commercial
real estate obviously took a major hit
now things have sort of recalibrated
people are you know you see Jamie
Diamond saying hey we'll just work from
work from home was sort of done or
whatever that story was what what's that
correlation typically and where is it at
today I'm trying to understand those
Dynamics this is what this is so
commercial real estate obviously there
was a there was a major decline during
coid but but residential major boom
maybe what's the typical correlation
where's it at today is what s more I'm
so you okay so go to that story that's
actually a good story to go into so JP
Morgan CEO Jamie Diamond says AI could
bring a three and a half day work day
work week uh go let's read this article
So Co Jamie Diamond your the benefits of
artificial intelligence uh which is
already being used by thousand of
employees at the bank and he predicts
it'll Usher in the norm of a shortened
work with your children are going to
live to 100 and not have cancer because
of technology and literally they'll
probably be working three and a half
days a week Dam Diamond says the banks
investment and AI will add huge value
and is being leveraged across the firm's
research trading customer service and
other functions when as of technology is
likely to replace on Bank jobs he
responded that of course it will but
that technologies will all all always
replace jobs
he also added that bank hires 30,000
people Year and that he expects many
displaced workers will be transferred to
new locations with Rolos with the new
company as many as 300 million jobs
around the world could be affected by AI
according to a recent Goldman Sachs
report and about one in five workers
have a job with high exposure to AI
according to P Research Center through
its unclear if AI enhance or displac
these roles so okay you read all this
stuff like for example this one building
we're looking at right this building in
February of 20 20 which is what right
before coid yeah the month before they
spent
$250 per square feet to upgrade a
300,000 foot building so how much is
that 250 time 300,000 is how much of an
upgrade the cost oh my that's a $75
million investment to do upgrades okay
and they did it right it's a great
building it's an incredible what's the
building's price but before all this Pat
hang on I interrupt
it's a $90 million let say building they
fixed this thing up 300,000 ft looks
amazing beautiful facility gym you know
uh uh what do you call it uh um uh um
cafeteria all this stuff it's just
ridiculous setup
right the company's a nearly a $4
billion company MH to them $75 million
like you know it is money but it's not
like we got to make the upgrades timing
is important they really SC that's the
problem so you signed a contract Co hits
oh God now everybody's working from home
now when you go into this facility and
you look the entire building have to
building is empty people have been
working from home during coid they're
sitting there saying what the hell do we
do with this building we want to get
this thing off our balance sheet they
don't want this building nor do they
need this building yeah okay with where
they're at and somebody bought them out
some 16 17 billion company bought this
building out and they're sitting they're
saying what do we do now this is case
study that's happening right now and by
the way this is happening across the
board there's another building here down
the street 200,000 ft building okay
office bace just 3 years ago it was
rented 90% so 200,000 Square ft was
rented 90% okay it's the Kaplan building
it's a Kaplan you know Kaplan that's
their headquarters today it's pretty
much empty and when I tell you empty I'm
like maybe it's rented 25 %. from 100%
you know 90% to now 25 to 50% how are
you collecting mortgage payments now
you're not and this is in a market
that's attracting businesses meaning
we're not talking about San Francisco
right here this building right here wow
193,000 foot building okay we're not
talking
about a you know San Francisco or
Chicago or New York or any of those
markets cream of the crop Florida that
people are mov into empty buildings
Class A Beautiful buildings sitting
empty on the complete opposite side
industrial buildings where people can do
like shipping like yeah you know what
Amazon does and some of these other no
those are jam-packed those like getting
space no no they're not having a hard
time selling industrial buildings they
don't have a hard time selling they
don't have a hard time you know they
have a hard time buying oh wow they
can't find enough of that got you Tom
and and by the way let's paint let's
draw let's draw a line so those
industrial buildings that are being
turned into wholesale distribution
centers who are they being turned into
for Walmart and for Target and ladies
and gentlemen and Amazon cuz they're
still delivering stuff to your home and
in certain blue cities are you paying
attention your target just closed that
doesn't mean Target doesn't want to sell
you stuff it means they couldn't afford
to have the public retail open and so
now they've got distribution stuff
because they still want to deliver to
you they still want to sell you stuff at
Target they're just not going to have
Smash and grabs and have um employees at
risk so they need commercial work house
space and they're competing with Walmart
and competing with Amazon to go find it
so that that is a very rich Market where
they're actually competing and bitting
each other up and so Pat that that um
who was it Jamie Diamond said it where
you know your kids your grandkids are
going to live to be 100 years old but
and then he said you're going to work
three and a half uh days days a week now
is that because they want you to work
from home or is it because the AI are
going to be taking your jobs and guess
what they're like listen we don't want
to get rid of you completely but just
you'll be there a little bit because
robots are basic going to take I mean
just think about it I I think I'm one of
the only guys in my 40s that still reads
a physical newspaper okay you know I
actually like reading a physical
newspaper yes when's the last time you
saw somebody reading a physical you're
literally I I read it sometimes just for
Nostalgia just I want to hold yeah but
but the point is like newspapers are
done there used to be a time newspapers
were it radio is done podcast is killing
it right cable TV is about to be
destroyed it may take 5 to 10 years but
they're going to get crushed right maybe
just maybe the next thing that's going
to get destroyed may be commercial real
estate in a big way wow it may get
crushed in a big way if they're going
this direction because what'll happen is
if you can have ai doing a lot of the
work if you can have ai doing a lot of
the work why do I need a big fancy
building to be in I don't most
Industries are not going to need it some
will most Industries are not going to
need it so they're going to experience
their they used to say there was the
death of the modern American Mall right
like why the hell do we need all this
space retail shopping but what that
forced malls to do uh was get creative
all right so maybe what are we going to
do with all this space all right so
rather than having retail uh shops
Galore let's set up an amusement park
let's put a roller skating rink in there
yeah when you have all this massive
amount of property and there's segments
of the market like retail why do you
need to go shopping necessarily you can
just go online um it just forces you to
get more creative and Tom you might know
this but the death of the mall was that
premature I don't know how many malls
actually closed down uh do you know that
number no I don't know the number but I
know Westfield took it in the chops
they're a large operator of of malls and
you look at what happened in San
Francisco uh you see these horrible
pictures on Twitter it looks like some
dystopian future you know weird space
thing where the mall's completely
desolate and homeless people have have
moved in there so the the malls you know
you've got malls that are still out
there operating but the typical mall has
has taken a bath and I'll tell you
something else H from The Venture side
of it so I'm not going to name any
companies but there is a gold ress of
companies out there that take your cell
phone and you know your friend or your
spouse just uh you you you wear your
underwear and you take pictures of the
front back and side of you and they give
you like a 90% accuracy of fit of
clothing because clothing fit and
clothing return was one of the first big
challenges of e-commerce you buy a shirt
this isn't a medium this is too tight
you know and you couldn't tell well now
you have all these tools that are out
there that are that are going to take
away what many people think is the Last
Frontier of the mall the ability to look
at and um uh and and and shop for
clothing that it's going away you'll be
able to see yourself in the clothing
size yourself in the clothing and that
the death of the mall is is is coming
quickly on a generalized State now
they're in Newport Beach California
there's a mall there fascist Island and
it's uh it's still there you know
there's high dollar communities that
still have their malls but malls are
have you been in the mall late League
Tom they're there it's sad in there this
this is sort of my point here this is
sort of what I was studying the decline
of the American mall has left just 700
Still Standing soon there may be 150
left this is in 2022 if you scroll down
a little bit Rob um there just 150
malles left United States in 10 years
according to one industry Watcher that's
his speculation there are currently
around 700 Mes in the US down from 20
500 in the 80s malls have suffered as an
online sales B so here's my hypothesis
this is just you know not not a
commercial Mall expert yeah the need for
malls was a need for shopping that's
where you would go get your stuff your
merchandise your clothes you just do
some general stuff the thanks buddy um
so that might obviously decrease with
the boom of you know online shopping but
what we've realized has not decreased is
the need for
hanging out in public yeah no and
the need to be around people and the
need to go out and the need to socialize
and then the quite frankly they just
need to be around people and malls
represent that they've always
represented that so you might not be
going to the mall anymore to go shopping
and do your typical thing but there
might
be SS but those people are paying the
rent right that sounds great and all but
these guys are not running a nonprofit
organization you're going to have to
spend money no but my point is that's
why they're going to get creative
instead of having ret Outlets like
there's some malls that are opening up
amusement parks or they're opening up
big movie theater type situations or
things that people will congregate they
got to get really creative though that's
my point they got to get really really
cre we could dive into this deep and I
know Pat's got other stories here but
I'm going to give you two quick points
if I could Pat real quick you're going
to see Innovation and Venture Capital
out there think of these guys this is
one of many companies that's doing this
they convert vacant Office Buildings
into housing um into 900t apart
Apartments mini apartments and things
like this they do that number one and
then number two you're seeing things
such as um it was on my case study I'm
not pimping for the the company Pat but
you're going to see many companies like
freerange Concepts in Dallas which is
this guy that owns three different
restaurants one is called The Rustic
that actually has a music and open air
area behind the restaurant to your exact
point I don't just go to the restaurant
I want to hit with sit with my friends
and the malls are not going to operate a
nonprofit for you to sit around the food
court at the all and chat for each other
but restaurants are doing that he also
has a a restaurant that's almost like a
Chili's but it caters to people with
dogs and there's this big area in the
center where you can actually walk your
dog so what's happening is the need for
Community is being met in other ways by
entrepreneurs because you're exactly
right where do we go to hang out
together hey there's my friend from high
school he was walking the other way in
the mall and he just bought a pair of
jeans and I would see them and talk to
them and that need in in in our
humanness is still there but it's not
going to be at the malls and I see
things happening with um Innovative
restaurant Concepts and other things to
meet the human need have you ever been
to the Mall Americas in Minneapolis
Minnesota god no I've never I've never
been there but it was like the uh people
people would say if God had a mall in
heaven it would look like this and
that's my point Rob I don't know if you
can find some images this is this is the
big I think the biggest mall in the
country maybe the world but you go there
and what they've done is they've
innovated so this is what's going on in
the you go full on amusement parks in
the mall so maybe you're not going to
abber cray and Fitch over here but
you're going to their version of
Disneyland in your local mall and that's
kind of what I'm saying you got to get
creative maybe you don't go to dve
Busters anymore you go to the mall or
something like that well yeah you make a
point but again this is there's only
one you know the malls of America yeah
there's only one of that it's a very big
investment for them to make some of them
depends on the market you're in is it
going to work is it not going to work
but the business model is going away so
the business model of commercial real
estate may be going away unless if
companies find ways to get people like
for me I'm always going to be an
in-office guy I'm I I I I'm always going
to be that guy I'm I'm running companies
we I think culture people got to be
around each other right to do that but
we have the predictive you know AI guys
that are typically quiet guys that want
to be by themselves they don't have to
be in a building they actually don't
want to be around a lot of other people
sometimes they have a different wiring
on where they want to be to that world
things are going to change a lot so this
commercial real estate deal on what
direction it's going to go the next 6 12
18 months it may be as permanent as
newspapers just maybe maybe we don't
know yet it just maybe but let's go to
the next story so check this out bad
policies have consequences how bad to
the point where Starbucks closed down
seven of them in downtown San Francisco
go due to bad policies let me read this
to you this is a fox business story uh
Starbucks is closing seven downtown uh
San Francisco stores including locations
at Mission and Maine Gary and Taylor
pickups only Fourth and Market Bush and
vaness with closures effective October
22nd Starbucks regional vice president
for NN California Jessica Borton
explained there are several factors
Starbucks considered before when uh
tasked with the tough decision of
closing a store but it is all part of
ensuring a healthy store portfolio
employees at the stores marked for
closure will be offered transfer
opportunities to near locations bort and
insured transfer opportunities are
available and will be offered to each
impacted partner we remain committed to
continuing dialogue and support okay so
seven Starbucks in San Francisco that's
a lot P that's a lot that's a lot of
from for for downtown that's that is
insane and you're not just talking about
anywhere you're talking about in San FR
that's a business Hub that there's
exective Ives running around that they
want to have their coffee in the morning
you know they may want to get a coffee
at lunch shutting down seven of them Tom
go for it those are not the slum areas
and you know Vinnie they need to call
their Congressman yep but you
know yeah but you know what sucks Tom
she just had to vacate she had to shut
down her office she got evicted yeah so
there's a lot of San Francisco evictions
going on P Pelosi's she's gonz on you
know you know her attitude does she have
anything to do with the policies that
ended yeah it's really really weird but
nobody brings it up but you know she
said this eviction is a sharp departure
from tradition but what do you think
about it Tom I I I I think it's pretty
freaking ironic that the princess of bad
policy is actually the same week it's
evicted from her office for other
reasons but hey look Vinnie what have we
been seeing in terms of a business's
clothing and like Macy's closing and and
Nord CL and the mall the the flagship
mall that was down there and Moscone
Center anchor stores they call Anchor
stores and it's and and I think is where
you're going with all the crime and
everything where when the bad policies
of Newsome and everybody that they go
Hey listen you could go in there and you
could steal but if it's under a th000
you're good what that's inviting people
to come in to destroy the business to
shut a down pad so that only PE places
like um Amazon and all these all these
places Thrive I I it's not it's not an
accidental thing I think they're doing
it on purpose cuz once think about it
Pat I just saw a thing where seven on
Rodeo Drive in Beverly Hills All Saints
all these huge stores are shutting down
cuz people don't want to do that
business Smash and grabs Smash and grabs
and they're saying by the way why we
even well by the way this holiday season
if you have a girlfriend why the hell
would you go and buy her $1,000 anything
put on a mask go inside of a wall no I'm
dead Pat I'm being dead serious you're
not going to go to jail why why like
baby what do you want okay put on the
mask and go break it that's what I would
do that's how much I love you
baby I'm willing to not go to jail for
you can you imagine that though baby
that's me right she's like that's not
you I'm like look look at my traps are
my traps you know who this is on though
who this is on your favorite word Vinnie
the constituents the constituents listen
if this is what you want you want more
of this if you're in San Francisco this
is Pat what do you say decisions and
actions have consequences it's just
which ones you're going to get but but
here's my question to you guys why
remember you always say follow the money
at them why are they letting this happen
this isn't just accident because when
you ask them they act like it's not a
problem it's not a problem Pat why why
why why I'm just curious the best again
the best part about say say you know
your ex says you will never turn into
anything you're a loser you'll never be
anything without me yeah okay guess what
we're going to find out in 10 years
whether she's right or wrong yeah right
you know you're you're you're working
out of place you guys will never make it
without me this company lost a great
employee without me okay maybe you're
right maybe you're wrong 10 years we're
going to tell these are the best
policies how dare you you know come to
our city we welcome you New York York we
welome wide open we will treat you doors
are wider we have hotels we have
locations we have to make it very clear
that you can no longer come to New York
City because we are done we can't do
nothing bad policies It Takes by the way
did you see what happened with Chicago
so Chicago did you see the protesting
the the folks in Chicago had over this
gym type Chicago gym okay uh uh just
type in Chicago gym and look what's
going on over there the the protesting
going on the gym you okay right there if
you can turn that on so they want to use
this gym in Chicago you can press play
so people can see for migrants yeah for
migrants and locals are saying dude what
are you talking about this is ours you
work for us this is Chicago we can pause
it this is a hardcore liberal City
that's sitting there saying why are you
turning our gym for our kids for for
migrants but by the way everybody's in
that audience too if those of you that
are listening to the podcast on audio
that audience is very diverse
everybody's in that room this isn't one
part here here's the problem though 90%
of them voted for exactly what they're
getting and and they'll and guess what
they vote for them again they V so so
you can scream all you want and vote any
differently you're going to get the same
exact thing you're going to get so the
best part about time and bad policies is
Time Will Reveal everything we're in
Florida because this guy's policies were
great policies the santis had phenomenal
policies during Co people left
California and Chicago and New York
because of bad policies but it took time
to know whose policies were good or bad
the only thing I'll add to this is what
issue are concerns you the most as a
voter right so a lot of people are
single issue voters or they pay
attention to more personality than
policies I would argue that most people
aren't really tracking the the the
policies of certain people they're just
like ah they look on the screen ah you
know most people 40% 42% 45% just see an
r or see a d and they just going that
way boom most people aren't sort of
diving into the policies what's my point
you know James carille under Clinton
said what's the biggest issue for voters
well it's the economy stupid so for most
people it is your paycheck but for other
people you know it's Healthcare or it's
abortion or it's minimum wage like in
San Francisco the fight for 15 now they
want to raise it to 20 whatever it is so
maybe that's your biggest issue right or
maybe it's immigration at some point but
what I would recommend for most people
if you are open-minded is really take
the the Congress person or who you're
voting for at face value delve into
their specific policies and not just
what you typically vote for sort of see
what times have changed we're talking
about disruption we talked about the
mall talked about crypto we talked about
AI things have changed so astronomically
fast that maybe what you were
politically a few years ago who you
voted for a few years ago isn't exactly
where you're at today and like you take
that look at the people in Chicago
they're basically like enough's enough
and maybe those are the people that will
change this vote but but but going off
what Pat said and Pat and we both we we
agreed on it's like all this Adam All
This Disaster all this chaos they're
still going to vote for the same people
in the same party and it's almost like
what's that syndrome Tom where the Mist
Stockholm syndrome Stockholm syndrome
the girls getting kidnapped you start to
actually like your kidnappers as long as
they're not abusing you the de Democrat
I mean just I'm sorry it's not it's a
Democrat Republican thing people like
that have Americans have Stockholm
syndrome when it comes to the people cuz
they're like listen they're abusing me
they're all over me but I can't
I can't give up on these people AB this
is why Pat Uh was I think so correct is
that he thinks that Bluer cities or
specific Bluer states are going to get
Bluer and redder cities and redder
states are going to get redder because
you know your Vibe attracts your tribe
you know they say so some people like
yeah we we want immigration for
everywhere we want minimum wage for
everyone we want that and then some
people are like dude like how many
people you meet Dude I left California
because of it was ridiculous the prices
the gas Gavin new you know this some
people said I'm voting for that guy
again so check this out watch this watch
this here this is a hill story GOP holds
biggest lead on economy since 1991 this
is Gallop oh damn GOP holds biggest lead
Rob can you pull up this story here GOP
holds biggest lead on economy what P
since 1991 Gallup according to gall poll
53% respondents trust the Republican
Party more to ensure country's
prosperity in the coming years compared
to 39% look look at the chart right
there by the way oh D this is the
highest ever rob go a little bit higher
so we can see the timeline on the bottom
go a little higher oh does okay right
there so check this out right there look
at that
1990s look how high the blue was and how
low the red was oh my God okay is that
the 60s okay 56 look how high the blue
is is versus red so then red has come up
and look where Blue's at now people are
like we're sorry man the blue economic
policy is just not this is this
Gap the 14-point advantage is the widest
gap on a on the the question since mid
1991 it almost is up from 10p point gap
from last year is where it's at when you
look at this number the survey revealed
that 57% of those P those pulled trust
Republicans more to protect their
country from International Terror ISM
and Military threats in contrast to 35%
who trust Democrats this trust Gap is
one of the largest since question was
introduced in 2002 despite these leads
both parties still face public
dissatisfaction with 56% viewing the GOP
unfavorably and 58% viewing the
Democrats unfavorably additionally 44%
believe the Republican party is better
equipped to handle problems as they rise
while only 36% feel the same about the
Democratic party again this is the
gallop hole gallop is not left right
middle Gallop Gallop they're pretty
credible that little J the purple line
that was on there at the bottom people
that don't give two shits the PE no no
the people that have no opinion has
dropped to nothing which means everybody
has an opinion and they're all in as as
we've gone from 2020 2023 and things
have gotten a little tougher everybody's
in with a per they should and that jump
right there looks like the N haly Jump s
have an opinion go vote well this was
sort of the point that I was making that
it's as Pat says it's woken up to people
that you don't want to wake up listen
I'm just going through life I'm not
paying attention to this kind of stuff
you're like hold on what what's going on
but kind of look I don't want to rock
the boat here kind of exactly what we
talked about with Anne couter yesterday
Yeah by all metrics Republicans are up
big put Trump aside right because that's
a whole anomaly whether you like him
hate him you know all that put Trump
aside just the Republican brand seems a
lot more sane than the Democratic brand
these days as you can see in the results
by all metrics espe especially in the
economy if you just put a blank name
blank face Republicans are up in
National polls but Republicans like hold
my beer let's see let's kick out the uh
uh House Majority Leader let's cause
chaos we saw what Steve Bannon said
yesterday be as crazy as possible so
that's kind of my point is that
Republicans you know the what I will say
Democratic policy typically not as let's
just say uh good but their marketing is
way better than there's no question
about that there's no question about
that and basically we were just talking
about about this crisis with with
immigration but you can connect the dots
really really fast all those immigrants
were supposed to stay in red States like
Texas and Arizona and Florida and turn
them purple then blue over time except
the federal government put a lot of
those people on buses to those blue
cities and so you get what you vote for
and which leads to people on this chart
saying I Got Feelings let me say this I
did he say I Got Feelings he got
feelings
I've got a feeling okay
so I got this little I got this little
tinge coming up my leg so uh uh you know
you know what this does say though
here's here's a part that you got to
think about common sense prevails time
prevails unfortunately sometimes people
take way too long to get it that's the
problem people take way when somebody
says there's nothing wrong with an 8 9
10 11y old you know when these people
are saying it's okay for them to
transition oh yeah oh yeah yeah it's
totally fine yeah you like the common
sense person sister and says what the
what are you talking about yeah but the
people that are like well maybe they're
right yeah who are they yeah and then
those guys 10 years later 20 years later
I said that was a terrible idea but
Common Sense eventually prevails it does
sometimes it's at a cost of a great
country I want to go to another story
here with Trevor
Bower so Trevor Bower was a sa young
winner 32y old pitcher sa young winner
getting ready to get his2 200 million
contract that he was going to get
incredible pitcher he is stud stud up
studs he's doing a great he's doing
great stuff in baseball and then all of
a sudden this guy's a little bit loud
baseball doesn't like him MLB doesn't
like him he talks trash he he would call
the sa Young Award when he won what did
he call it the Mickey Mouse Mickey Mouse
sayong award the Mickey Mouse sayong
award and he wore Mickey Mouse shirts
with sayong he he would he would Vlog
while playing for major leagues I love
that he was a vlogger YouTuber while
playing for the major leagues he's a
professional poker and I don't mean
cards in many ways yes Trevor bow
accuser Trevor Bower's accuser Lindsey
Hall opens up on text and video claims
Lindsey Hill who accused Trevor Bower of
sexual assault responded to Bow's video
sharing text messages in a video to
support her his innocence she explained
that some of her text messages including
one that read next victim star pcture
for Dodgers were sarcastic and taken out
of context she also mentioned her that
her use of the word victim was
inappropriate but I'm meant in a serious
context I mean I just ruined the guy's
life for two years what's the big deal
he'll discuss a video B shirt in which
she appeared to be smiling after the
alleged assault she clarified that her
emotions were complex at the time and
the video was sent to her cousin to show
that everything was okay she explained
that bruises from such incidents can
take time to appear and mention
possessing selfies that demonstrate
physical injuries can you play the video
of Trevor B by the way can you just play
the clip I I want you to actually play
the clip of B from the beginning watch
this year by the way this guy is playing
in Japan now because Major League
Baseball suspended him for whatever the
number of game was then they lowered it
to 50 games what 194 games he lost $37
Million by the way he didn't lose $37
million guys during that time he was at
his pick of his career he was about to
get a $200 million bag is what he was
going to get that they took away from
him but play this clip here go forward
next victim star pitcher for this her
texting a text lindsy Hill sent to a
friend before she ever even met me what
should I steal she asked another in
reference to visiting my house for the
first time the answer take his money so
how might that work I'm going to his
house Wednesday she said I already have
my hooks in you know how I roll then
after the first time we met net worth is
51 mil she said you better secure
the bag was the response but but how was
she going to do that need daddy to choke
me out she said being an absolute
to try to get in on his 51 million
another text Jesus demon then after the
second time we met former Padre's
pitcher Jacob Nicks told her you got to
get this bag I'll give you 50,000
Lindsay replied her AA sponsor asked her
at one point do you feel a tiny bit
guilty not really she replied since then
her legal team has approached me
multiple times about coming to a
financial settlement but as I have done
since day one I refused to pay her even
a single scent good boy uh in August of
2021 lindsy Hills claims were heard in
court and during those legal proceedings
critical information was deliberately
and lawfully concealed from me and my
legal team uh information like this
video which was taken by Lindsay Hiller
self the morning after she claimed she
was brutally attacked emotionally
traumatized and desperate to get away
from me and now we have the metadata so
there can be no dispute uh it was taken
mere minutes before she left my house on
the morning of May 16th 2021 idiot
without my knowledge or consent of
course uh in it you can see her lying in
bed next to me while I'm sleeping
smirking at the camera without a care in
the world or any marks on her face I
think it paints a pretty clear picture
of what actually happened the evening of
May 15th and why the video was
originally concealed from
us yeah uh after hearing the evidence
available PA by the way she gets
confronted by did you see this when
she's getting confronted Rob do you have
that video who she get she gets
confronted on a podcast and a lady says
you texted this you said this you said
that you said this how do you feel about
it now well you know it's all being
taken out of context it's not really
true and it's it's not really this and
it's not really that you're supposed to
believe all women though Pat so by way
you have to believe her she's getting
paid 500 to5 Grand to be on these
podcasts ladies and gentlemen she is she
is a witness For Hire right now how do
you know she's getting paid that kind of
money because she needs money she's
freaking broke and the and people get
paid to be on podcast and by the way by
the way she's getting paid she's getting
paid 500 she's not going on a podcast
for nothing well she also got a $300,000
settlement from the insurance company
and through her lawyers after this was
cleared most was going to her lawyers
this is her on this is a this is this is
her acting up drunk at an event just to
watch this year go for it same girl me
too actually
oh she's an evil look at that hate
in her oh she's an
[Music]
angry I'm sorry I down that Metro's
coming well I want to make sure nothing
Happ she drinking a blood light it all
makes sense that's all you need perfect
forget it she's drinking that demon
juice the official beer of cheat of
cleat chaser bringing that demon juice
brother look uh you know sham Anderson
over here right here now like this is
actually there's so many different ways
we can go with this situation you
know the height of 2017 2018 the me too
movement Harvey Weinstein would get it
that was actually true right and he was
held accountable for that so so was
someone like Bill C Les Mo L Moon we all
know what happened so there's men out
there they're like what the hell is
going on cuz you see what's going on out
there where men you know they're being
called gropers or certain other words or
Grapist just because they want to go
talk to women in public some breaking
story on Tik Tok some guy just tried to
approach a girl at the gym she's like
he's a assaulting me he's like I just
said what's up but here's on the surface
obviously men see something like this
like this is ridiculous but I think
going deeper who should be the most
upset are actually women because if you
put aside these nonsensical fabricated
manufactured stories there actually are
real stories about women that deal with
issues and what happens when these women
full on lie is now it's the pendulum has
swung the complete opposite way to the
whole believe all women is now it's the
boy who cried wolf syndrome or the girl
who cried wolf syndrome and they're like
yeah how do we know this is true vitim
seen what's happened here's my point
we've seen what's happened well it turns
out Amber herd was a freaking liar and
she actually has to pay $8 million to
Johnny Depp for defamation turns out you
know Russell Brand we'll see what
happens with him probably fake news type
of thing turns out Andrew Tate Tristan
Tate yeah turns out these allegations
they don't really have any evidence it
turns out I've done several of these
things on my show oast where they
literally show a woman on a podcast
she's like a famous rapper not cardi B
we'll get that in a second who literally
said her boyfriend was being mean or
whatever and she thought he was cheating
so what did she do she called DCF on him
Department of Child and Family Services
and said that he was abusing his kids
and on camera admitted this is actually
on uh Adam 22 I believe uh they took the
kid she said I full on lied and I got
him back sorry about that I'm yelling
but I'm little passion but what's my
point is that account ility needs to be
to happen for these women for all the
the guys that did wrong stuff you're
talking about the Harvey wiin of the
world and Bill KY World where's the
accountability watch ladies that have
watch this video just play this short
clip it's it's a longer interview but
just watch this 15-second clip that's a
great question it's a really really
valid question I think that's a really
good question how I phrased it and I
think it's a super valid question
everything you're asking me is a super
valid I agree that's why I'm asking
again super valid you know what that's
something my lawyers would have to
by the way it's embarrassing everything
she asks she's like so why would you
text him this you know you were doing
this you were trying to get the money do
you realize what you did to him oh it's
a valid question it's a valid question
it's a super valid such a good question
so so so to point out what Trevor Bowers
this okay sounds good Trevor Bow's right
okay cool now he's in Japan yeah okay
he's big in Japan right now okay they
love him he's the tallest guy tallest
guy there he's a no they love they love
him in ja he's a foreign player over
there they love him in Japan but tell me
the greatest Japanese hitter of all time
and how many hits and home runs has he
have Suzuki s h oh okay of course Tom
knows it is that who it is yeah what
about the guy Rob help me out here yeah
no no Rob's not GNA help you out point
is what's the most home run someone hit
in in the Japanese League I think o oh
almost got to Babe Ruth how many home
runs did he hit but how many home runs
did Roger Maris hit here uh 61 for his
record season how many did Babe hit in a
season 74
no season what's the most Barry Bonds
hit 74 I believe what did Barry Bonds
and what did Mark Mark McGuire and Samy
SAA Do It Was a Race 70 and 66 I see
where you're going here nobody knows
about the hell do you know about
Japanese this guy's an american guy he
wants a legacy in America not in Japan y
so this guy wants that here so now
Dodgers are you going to you know tweet
out an apology jum MLB are you going to
put an apology for what you did to this
guy are you going to do that because
this whole concept you know half my
frustration yesterday was you know when
we're having this conversation with this
guy about Trevor bow is this this notion
of guilty until proven innocent you
destroy the guy's life how about
innocent until proven guilty you this
you suspended the guy based on
allegations the girl made that were
wrong right and now what his life impa
and think great Point his legacy his
name cuz I don't care because we talked
about this the other day Pat unusual
suspects the average person like this
they're not doing the research that
you're doing right now the average
person that sees him and then seees his
name you know what they're going to say
rapist abuser beater guy that's it per
for the rest of his life how much do you
think he's going to sue Pat cuz he's
going to go after everybody but it
doesn't matter even if he does I mean
this this is this is this is part of the
problem who's this girl you're talking
about is this the girl you're talking
about there's nothing worse in this
world than being wrongfully accused of
something you didn't do so Trevor B I
feel for you brother I mean are you
kidding me this especially after the
fact what's going on here like you see
these things going on
where you know breaking news Man
released from prison after being
wrongfully accused for 28 years and they
give him a check for $1.2 million well
here's this girl that I'm talking about
so there's a guy at the end of the story
who had his kids taken away but let's
not worry about that let's what are we
going to do with her we throwing her in
jail but she actively fullon full lied
watches podcast she is in no danger of
ever writing a Nobel Prize accepted
speech this one she I I call child
services on my ex because he pissed me
off and then I was like okay I'm done
with this person whatever like you know
cheater piece of liable
dumb you had kids I called child
services on his ass and got him I like
yeah fabricated everything and likeed
things and they like went to the door
and like there was a whole process like
I don't even know if the Children's Aid
worker still visits them but she
probably does because what ient like the
way I aied that you know like real
AI like fake bruises type by
the way if you go to if you go to Hell
she's an Administration obviously the
guy interviewing her won't even be seen
on camera but she'll so anything but
ladies this is my point dumm is like why
do should
women why should men actually have
respect for women who are willing to do
this like we've we all we we've seen
cardi B come out and say Yes before I
was a famous rapper I was a full-on
stripper I would go to G
drug them steal their Jack them if
a guy did that he would be held what
accountable women can just go on podcast
admit to getting guys kids taken away
from them and joke about it I a add that
where's the accountability means
too anybody if that's s to cut you off
Tom anybody any Rich successful famous
men this is a lesson to be learned you
cannot be hooking up one night stands
Rob Rob you talked about this too right
what did you say about the experience
she wanted the hair it was insane right
well the text
message yeah she was saying I want all
the pain Daddy needs to choke me out I
mean they're very
very favor but my point my point being
Pat if you're if you're like Pat if you
were single and you had no kids and
you're out there by the way he's out
there he's doing this thing you not only
have to have contracts you have to have
a camera you have to have hey what's
your Sarah we're hooking up right it's
cool if I pull your hair and choke you
it's to that point so I'm not blaming
him but at the same token you're this
guy you're in the public eye the demons
are out looking for you on these moments
the only thing I'm happy about about
this story is though Tom you think that
chick will ever bang a guy with money
she's going to be banging dudes from
Walmart let me tell you unfortunately I
think you're wrong CU I think that a
girl who's hot enough will find some trp
she's not that hot she's not that hot
whether it's her's Walmart hot yeah Rob
you'd see her at Walmart there's a
blueprint and there's a game plan for
these types of girls and if they're not
held accountable we'll see what happens
I've been around guys big time dudes
they literally make girls sign ndas
before they even walk in the house hell
yeah literally before you walk into this
house party sign this form right here I
agree that nothing Pat you've done a
whole video where guys have to be like
so hey what's up me and Mary right here
we about to do our righty sucks but if
you're that dude or Trevor Bower has 200
million do on the line you know using a
sports reference you can play offense
you got to play some defense you got to
have insance we could go on this for a
long time this morning CU there's three
three topics here I'm going to bring up
really really fast the first the first
is we're living in a in a world where we
have the
politicization of of basically the
criminal justice system and the Pasadena
Police Department I'm going to stay away
from everything we're talking about here
to my second point the Pasadena Police
Department sat on this stuff when Trevor
Bower said metadata he was talking about
text messages that the Pasadena Police
Department got because they gave a
subpoena to AT&T and Verizon and they
got the real text messages your phone
erase it from your phone it's in the
servers at the uh that the the cell the
wireless carrier your mobile provider
they had all of it and they sat on it
and do you remember how long the
Pasadena Police Department sat on it and
didn't file charges did not file charges
they never filed a criminal charge
against this guy and they dropped it
they were waiting for it to come out of
the news they were feeling pressure that
if they went out and basically said
there's nothing to see here we're not
going to prosecute that the the
political machine was going to come down
on the da and the da the prosecutor in
Pasadena was scared squatless to say you
know nothing to see here because they
had the video and they had all this
stuff so we're living in a political
realm and the second is let me tell you
you know when you live in a hookup
culture there's consequences every
college in America is doing orientation
for their male athlet and there's a
phrase that's on those cuz I've seen
some of the power points it's called
Cleat Chasers and they say hey you going
to find some girls that are perfectly
good how
that CLE like cleat oh okay oh we
thought you were getting freaky they're
also called Jersey jumpers and they're
also called uh and they use phrases that
are not sexist but they're saying hey
what we're talking about here they it's
not an anti-woman word it's just a
description of people that want to chase
you around and be with you and be part
of the party and in the middle of that
there may be girlfriend friends but
there may be some very bad actors that
are in the middle of the crowd there
it's hey I'm a big athlete I got all the
stuff going on I'm living in a hookup
culture here at University of whatever
and you've got the university now that's
warning these guys hey you know what you
need to be careful about this because we
will cut you we will drop you and it's
about to get worse on campus my third
point because of niil name image
likeness you now have college kids that
are going to have real money in their
pocket and it's about to come down a
level to less mature men who are going
to get attacked like Trevor Bower did
because you're going to be a college
player with a $2 million contract so
well and that's by the way my last point
so we can go on because Pat's got the
next topic what did they tell you in the
military when you went out not clubing
not going to New York cuz you had
military dollars 15 will get say it
again 15 will get you 20 and always have
who with you always have a Budd Ranger
buddy yeah a witness well was Rob you
want to say something just real quick
the timeline of this pet not and and Tom
brought it up the Pasadena Police
Department declined to press charges
against uh Trevor Bower the Los Angeles
County District Attorney's Office also
declined to press charges against him
the judge who issued the restraining
order lifted the restraining order
citing that he honored the woman's uh
wishes in regards to rough sex he didn't
go past the boundaries and despite all
of that Major League Baseball still
decided to suspend him for
324 games it's called the foot dragon
suspension the biggest suspension in
Major League Baseball history cuz they
dragged their feet and you know you know
what's scary thank God this guy has
money could you imagine the guys that
are out there Pat that and John had
money yeah imagine but yeah but think
about the average guy that's just like I
got freaky what she wanted me jail 20
years you're finished if you read musk's
book yeah if you read B brother first of
all whatever guys do whatever you can go
read his book while his second wife was
crazy trained yeah if you read his book
you'll see what Kimble talks about Amber
herd Kimble's his brother what his
family says about Amber herd you're
going to learn more about Amber herd in
this book oh great then the documentary
oh because it's going to be on the
inside what his insiders thought of her
that's what you have to read go forward
let's wrap it up guys 30 seconds on this
topic here's my last point just how
Harvey Weinstein or Bill Cosby are the
poster child the face of men who do this
to women right cuz that is a real thing
proven guilty those guys right proven
guilty women who do this whether it's
cardi B whether it's Amber herd to a
certain extent they need to be the
poster child the face and held
accountable for what they've done wrong
to Men Let 10 of them go to jail for 20
years that's my point like women need to
learn a lesson you lie about this kind
of stuff you get some dude's kids taken
away you lie about getting choked out
abused but it turns out you were into it
just to steal $50
million when they go to jail when this
girl whatever her freaking name is
Lindsay Hill Goes to Jail then women
will be like oh you know that
Playbook yeah maybe let's not use that
this time especially right now you got
proof everything can be shown and traced
right now you can BS today people going
to see the text messages the WhatsApp
all of that stuff let's go to the next
story next Story one final final comment
no I'm not doing it Tom we're going to
go to the next story because everybody's
giving their last comment 15 times next
story all right so next story we want to
get to is do we want to do Water Crisis
or adults shouting at children let's do
all shouting at children okay so check
this out folks you're going to lose your
mind and you're actually going to go
zero to angry in less than one minute
ready so check this out CNN pull up the
story adults shouting at children can be
as harmful to a child's development as
sexual abuse let let let me let me read
this to you one more time folks please
just hear me out CNN story written by IC
Ronald Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023
at 50:06 p.m. adults shouting at
children can be as harmful to child's
development as sexual abuse or phys
physical abuse a new study publishing
child and abuse neglect studies shows
that adults shouting denigrating or
verbally threatening children can be as
damaging to their development as
physical or CH uh sexual abuse the study
which
viewed reviewed earlier studied calls
for childhood verbal abuse to be
recognized as distinct category of
maltreatment to facilitate prevention
efforts childhood verbal abuse
classified as subtype of emotional abuse
can have lifelong negative consequences
including mental distress externalizing
symptoms like criminal Behavior or
substance abuse and physical health
issues such as obesity or lung cancer
the study underscores the importance of
acknowledging and addressing the impact
of verbal abuse on children not not
single mother you know no father in the
household not not not teaching lgbtq in
school not that stuff no that's totally
fine fine it doesn't at all mess with
the kids at all God forbid a mother
raises her voice on kids it could be as
worse more harmful than sexual abuse Tom
as a parent how do you read this story
as a parent what do you think about this
nonsense here you know what here's what
I think about it it's ludicrous your
child walks across a kitchen and you go
don't touch that hot stove and your wife
says you great now he's
gay just like what are you it's like
yeah I I I think it I think it's
horrifying now you may I've raised my
voice to my girls absolutely raised my
voice usually when they were you know
giving an argument and you know thought
maybe they could tell me something four
times in a row seeing if I'll finally
believe it's true you know every parent
has that and I've raised my voice stop
we're not doing that sit down r a talk
here and and so but it's not yelling I
think there's a on the concept of
yelling there's a difference between
yelling and belittling and just
destroying your kids self-confidence and
then being a parent and raising up the
volume that says look this is serious
you're not going to lie to me because if
you're lying to me here you're going to
be lying to your school teacher school
teacher after school there's a slippery
slope here and we're going to talk about
integrity and telling the truth and
being honest that's not yelling that is
correction that is processing with your
kids but there is there is like drunk
parent yelling and belittling but does
it lead to being as damaged
as you know you know father felacio was
was basically abusing you for 10 years
at the local Paris I don't think so I'll
add this man uh there's levels to this
okay uh I think we can all agree sexual
abuse zeroi zero tolerance for that
whatsoever it's like how you're even
comparing it to physical or or verbal is
absolutely asinine okay physical abuse
there's levels to that like I you know
I've been open on this I had a very
rough relationship my father like he was
very quick to take the belt out put it
that way but sometimes a kid does need a
little little uh what do you call it a
little pow pow little something
something I get it there's levels to
that too there's
fullon abuse of a kid but then there's
like all right like I used to get my
mouth washed out with soap didn't really
work cuz I'm still out here cursing on
there I got to work on that but there's
levels to this when it comes to verbal
abuse I mean there's levels to that too
Tom hit the nail on the head where he
said look if you're just berating
someone and King him to lose all right
like you know I don't have kids but I
I'm very active in my nephew's life I
was a teacher I was a cam counselor I've
been around kids believe me as a teacher
or as a dealing with kids you're going
to raise your voice okay I'm very cool
my nephew's like my best friend I love
that kid he's 10 years old the other day
he's riding his bike in the street I go
get out of the Street cuz
sometimes you have to raise your Goddamn
voice and and did you you said that and
he was like rap you raped me he he got
so shook cuz I don't talk to I feel so
dirty he got so shook cuz I yelled and I
never yell at this kid but I had to
emphasize my point bro you're riding
your bike way too close to the street
you freaking idiot get out of the street
now why don't I want you to do that cuz
I love you and I want you to be alive so
to to to bring this all in sexual are
you freaking kidding me c it's not even
comparable this is C this by the way
it's pretty embarrassing to have the
brand like if some some blog wrote this
okay whatever the brand CNN is okay with
this being written about of course they
are of course they are and it's CNN
Health by the way yeah think just to
kind of like they're so worried about
your health think and GH riding for you
guys think about it pat we were
disciplined and guess what I I think you
you turned out pretty good you know the
the popw work and if you think about it
if you can't discipline if you can't
discipline po yeah if poow if you can't
discipline the kids then the the kids
can do whatever they want because they
know that there's no consequence
noqu they do whatever they want they
break and they say you know what I want
toop my crotch off Dad and what you what
are you going to do you're going to hit
me you're going to say you can't say
none of that and that leads Pat to like
to bigger pictures and bigger problems
which we have right now with you know
them pushing the agendas and the kids
and the lgbtq all the children stuff
which is a whole different and if
there's no yeah CU I was just going to
say yeah please Pat cuz this this goes
to my point look at this Trickle
effect and some people like oh Vinnie is
crazy no no I'm not connecting dots the
dots are right in front of your face why
is it pat that Hollywood uh all these
weird Epstein people they're always
pushing the lgbtq agenda people nobody
nobody ever takes a step back why CU
they care about your kids and their
their freedom and for for their their
choice of no no if you think about it
and then why when movies come out time
what was the sound of U freedom of
Freedom Adam sound the silence the sound
of freedom and nobody in Hollywood cares
nobody big was pushing it what Jim cavel
one guy they kind of want to keep on the
hush hush because I saw I saw a video by
Dr Omar Johnson where he's like if
you're a pedophile he's like if I was a
pedophile guess what I would push the
lgbtq movement and he said you know why
because if the kid's old enough at that
age to change their body who are you to
say that they can't have sex that's the
argument Rob can you play that play that
video it's a short video but he really
makes a really really good point and I
want you guys to see her play
this this guy's no like he Pat no holds
he doesn't hold back any punches he
tells he tells it exactly how it is I am
a
pedophile I don't want to go to jail I
want pedophilia to become normal I want
it stricken from the criminal code allog
together I'm going to push lgbtq check
it because if a child is old enough to
decide I never want to have children
take my testicles take my ovaries if a 8
9 10 11 year old child is old enough to
make those three
decisions how can you argue that they're
not old enough to decide to have sex
Bingo the argument of the pedophile is
going to be backed up by this LGBT
Crusade against our children because in
their sick minds they are rationalizing
the argument before the courts if he's
old enough to say I don't want my
testicles if she's old enough to say I
never want to have children if he's old
enough to say I want to live Life as a
girl if she's old enough to say I want
to live a life as a boy and I don't care
about having kids and she can say this
at 12 is she not also old enough to
decide when she's ready to have sex what
what what a what a great simple simple
point and that's why you see it P that's
why you don't see it cuz it's like you
said Tom the supply supply chain they
don't want you messing with this Le let
them be they want to give them the
mature mindset as a young kid bro so
they could just do whatever the hell
they want want with them cuz if a kid at
that age you know decision no discipline
no nothing that's the type of that
I'm talking there's lunacy in here too
I'm going to ask Pat three quick
questions Pat Tico and Dyan out there
playing baseball bang break the
neighbors front glass window at their
has never happened before very or maybe
kicking a soccer ball it goes right into
some really expensive window of your
neighbor's house you know your kids are
under 14 who pays for that window daddy
correct kid goes at school whips out the
dicksa you don't get to know about it
and then they're very very upset they
have a fight with another child they
break three teeth out of the front who
pays for that Daddy correct until
they're 18 years old yeah so there is
there are two big forces coming together
here parents are told that you are
financially responsible for things they
do all the way up to x yet all the
things that they that they keep from the
parents are sexually related all the
responsibility no one has taking away
any responsibility on parents to do
anything every single thing abortion get
birth control school you know um gender
reassignment crossdressing labeled as
trans all of that is kept from the
parent it's sexualization and you just
made a great point about it it is Supply
Chain management America that is
happening before your very eyes yep and
when they act like it's not happening it
yeah but you know what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen God no
look of course but look what happened in
Chicago migrants should be using our gym
and we should give it to no you my kids
over migrants okay exactly oh oh we
agree yes hey yeah what's wrong with
this lgbtq and then your 12year old son
comes home Mommy I think I'm a girl no
you're not what are you f how to do what
would you do this my school exactly
eventually time is going to be on common
sensus s I'm going to keep saying this
eventually everyone's going to Real
realized these were all dumb by the way
did you notice some of the craziest
wildest policies came out during Co some
of the things that created all this
momentum was during Co by the way check
this out next story World economic uh
Forum adviser the coming Water Crisis
will force people to accept climate
mandates okay let me read it to you one
more time folks the coming Water Crisis
will force people to accept climate
mandates let's see where they're going
with this Mariana mazuk
okay an advisor to the world economic
Forum believes that the impending Water
Crisis will serve as a more relatable
and Urgent issue that climate change
stating water every kid knows how
important it is to have water so there's
also something about really getting
citizen engagement around this and
really in some ways experimenting with
the notion of common good mazuk suggests
that the world economic form may use the
water cry may use may
use as it's like a prop may use the
Water Crisis to
advance climate mandates may use to
climate mandates saying World economic
forums globalists may use water a
necessary substance for human life to
create Panic to advance their agenda and
force climate Man by the way this is
what she this is a quote let me read
this quote again go ahead the world
economic for globalist may use water a
necessary substance for human life to
create Panic ho keyword to scare the
crap out of you to advance their agenda
and forc climate mandates the world
economic Forum on its official website
emphasizes the impact of water related
crisis on societies particularly to the
poor and calls for governance of water
AS Global common good Vinnie and and
mind you and Rob has the video P so I
know everybody's always like thinks that
we're we're bananas but these people
these evil everybody at these places
that has an accent like CLA Schwab I
don't trust any of these people and she
actually said and this is what she's GNA
Say pat she said we try to vaccine
vaccinate the entire planet that failed
climate change is too abstract for
people to understand so basically what
she's saying is Pat you know what we're
going to have to do we're going to mess
with the water cuz all you idiots drink
water and this is this is evil right in
your face saying it watch this go ahead
also of course true with coid right we
are all only as healthy as our neighbor
is on our street in our city and our
region and our nation and globally and
did we solve that like did we actually
manage to vaccinate every the world so
highlighting water as a global common
and what it means to work together and
see it both out of that kind of global
comment perspective but also the
self-interest perspective because it is
it does have that parallel it's not only
important but it's also important
because we haven't managed to solve
those problems which had similar
attributes and water is something that
people understand you know climate
change is a bit abstract some people
understand it really well some
understand it a bit some just don't
understand it water every kid knows how
important it is to have water when
you're playing football and you're
thirsty you so there's also something
about really getting citizen engagement
around this and really in some ways
experimenting with this notion of the
common good can we actually deliver this
time in ways that we have failed
miserably other times and hopefully we
won't keep failing on the other things
but anyway you and by the way do you
realize when she said she looks like she
can man two plates 100% she look like
Arnold sister she uh the fact that she
just said Pat she goes we tried to
vaccinate everybody on the planet it it
didn't work then you know what she says
she goes climate change is too abstract
no you know what that you know
what abstract means we're not believing
in your BS okay the world's going to be
fine but for her to say out loud this is
when I say when evil is in your face and
they're smirking and they're laughing at
you she saying you know what when we
come after the water then it's going to
be a problem because guess what even
your kids drink this water that's scary
well the thing for me is there's the
problem and then there's the solution I
think most people are in agreement on
certain problems okay coid was a problem
all right uh global warming a problem
the Water Crisis it's actually real
especially in subsaharan Africa in the
Middle East it's Sahara Desert it's a
problem the question is the solution the
solution as we all know during coid
wasn't everyone has to get mandates
everyone has to get jabbed lock it down
probably not the best solution right we
had this conversation the other day with
our friend Liz like what's the solution
to global warming how much of is it
man-made when it comes to water you're
saying that they're using this OPP
they're being opportunistic to maybe
push the climate change agenda I mean
here's the facts according to Unicef on
the global Water Crisis 770 million
people lack access to clean water that's
one in 10 people almost people spend an
estimated 200 million hours every day
carrying water the average person walks
rural Africa 6 kilometers which is about
3.7 miles every day to ha 40 PBS of
water and um Urban water demand is is
expected to increase 80% by 20 2050
quote unquote UNICEF there's definitely
a global Water Crisis I don't think
anyone's objecting to the fact that
people need water there's a Water Crisis
especially in certain parts of the world
Africa the Sahara the Middle East
Lebanon Afghanistan like everyone in
there like but is the solution exactly
what the world economic Forum suggests I
would be very cautious whatever you know
you know the movie Big Short when the
movie ends and everybody's blown away by
this guy Michael
you know what the movie said at the end
what Michael bur's Focus was next after
the next Wars will be fought he over
water oh wow and you know when he said
that in 08 dude that guy's a he's a
freaking psychic that guy's good so
meaning like for everybody that's
watching this stop listening to the
podcast go to the near Vons go to the
nearest Al Ralphs or Albertson's or what
what is it Kroger's or what is it here
or yeah Sam's Club go quietly without
saying anything to the owner go quietly
fill up every single cart that you have
with every water they're selling and
just spy it and get one of those
commercial get one of those any reason
why you bu just a big party just a part
big part no reason I'll add one more
thing I mean we're so lucky here in
America that this is not our daily
lifely issue and when it is like Flint
Michigan a few years ago oh bro everyone
took notice oh Ancient Ancient pipes and
lead poisoning in the city what there's
no clean water and FL what is America
happening right now still problem we
just talked about in um East Palestine
right the water that was basically
turned toxic after
they thank God in America these are
oneoff segmented issues imagine being in
other parts of the world and literally
not having access to clean water so
think twice before you talk about
America go move anywhere else in the
world let me know how the water
situation good luck okay next story
miscellaneous American apocalypse uhoh
question mark 71% don't trust the US
government government to prevent
doomsday this is a study that just came
out yesterday obviously it's a very
inspiring story but let's go through it
a survey conducted by bonus finder.com
revealed that 71.2% of Americans have
lost faith in US Government ability to
save them from or prevent a doomsday
event with many believing that such an
event would occur within the next year
climate change related
catastrophic we're at the top concerned
with 55.8% of respondents fearing this
typ of Doomsday scenario additionally
third of respondents believed that
another virus could sweep the globe and
25% feared the start of World War II a
smaller percentage considered scenarios
like an alien invasion or events in 2024
the lack of trust in US government was
bipartisan 82% of respondents in the
swing state of Arizona expressing
distrust some respondents 16% cited
social media and content they consume as
influencing their doomsday preparations
While others pointed to news family and
movies okay uh Vinnie what do your
thoughts on the story well first of all
it's it's funny that 71% don't trust the
government to prevent doomsday aren't we
at the highest level of them don't
trusting the government to do anything
period with anything with politics and
everything so I think when it does come
to a doomsday event don't rely on the
government don't you have to rely on
yourself and I'm not talking about build
a bunker or do anything crazy like that
but listen Pat I don't know if you have
this do you have do you have like a to
go set up ready to go just in case God
forbid something happens where shit's
going down and you have to get everybody
in the car and go submarine parked
outside the
house and and I'm being serious I have a
bag at my house the oh just in case
you got a go bag and obvious thank God
you know what I'm saying I'm armed I
have guns and stuff but MREs I went to
the Army Surplus Store you have that
people don't think about I'm dead
serious Adam I'm not one of those guys
that's cuz you know Rob has a bunker in
Peter pry L just going there to Peter
pry yeah but God God for bid and I'm
hoping it never happens let's just say
Adam you get that emergency alert that
came on everybody's phone yesterday and
it's something's really happening what
are you going to go like this no no you
guys go I'm waiting for the government
FEMA's going to send me a thing no no
nobody's going to give a it's going
to be every man for himself so I think
you have to be uh be prepared to take
care of you on your own I'll tell you
what I mean thank God you have that back
the only thing I have is like an
overnight sleepover back quick we need
you out here boom I'm out I'm sleeping
up boom with your cats you have to bring
your cats extra bag of kibble there we
go I think um a lot of of people normal
people who would look at Doomsday
Preppers and you see those commercials
hey come over here to you know Arkansas
wherever Oklahoma and get your piece of
land and go underground people like the
hell these guys talk weirdos now
they're like you know what what was that
what was that place again what was that
thing again I think people are like
what's going on yeah the world has
changed so drastically but Pat brings up
a great point we had this guy Peter pry
on he's I think he's the only guest you
had on back to back within a month
really and and then he died it was crazy
what did he die of not in the middle of
the podcast he died couple months
after there's a lot of people that
actually really love that guy super old
it's actually worth watching because he
talked about how to build a e e EP what
was it called underground bunker yeah
underground but what it was called pmds
what was it called Rob Preppers no not
not sure I got to go back and look it
was you know sort of like nuclear
warfare there was uh yeah here it is
probably it is right here I do remember
we had back we had episode 155 and then
five episodes later we brought him back
to discuss and passed away called but
pass you know but the whole conversation
I had with him was like you know Mr pry
Dr pry I totally understand what you're
saying but most people are struggling
you know two-thirds of Americans living
paycheck to paycheck we see debt On The
Rise we see people basically complaining
about inflation interest rates now
you're telling me I got to go buy some
piece of property underground bunker in
Oklahoma and I got like who's buying
this he's like look I I hear you but go
get it and the ironic thing God Rest his
soul he died turns out he didn't need he
didn't need it but mean but at the same
time at least we have this Vault and
whatever property we get whatever new
property we get I totally recommend that
we hollow out the downstairs and have
one of
those little under by the way to be like
to be I'm not being funny what I'm
trying to tell you is have you seen the
Doomsday Bunkers like the high-end
luxury straight
here Rob can you show this link I'm
sending to you kind of sweet no no some
of these things and no like yeah it's
actually a big thing right that that one
right there on that one right there
watch this 11 luxury doomsday this is
real this is underground what the hell
yeah zoom in a little bit so we can see
the pictures keep like trump top Plaza
underground what for only 17 grand a
night you can keep going so this is an
underground apartment what yes keep
going this is another one keep going
this is a condo under look at that how
my God bro if you got the money if you
got the money it looks like that
building in Chicago if you ever see the
the circular building in Chic down
building going down oh my God imag can
you imagine that tridon Lake keep going
yeah get the prices on these though
that's what I want to know the prices on
Las Vegas underground shelter look at
this kids playground running around
doing their thing there's a game by the
way if if you can't afford one of these
you better befriend somebody that's one
of those crazy doomsday guys this that
house right there looks like that one
house where once a year you can kill
people Purge or whatever it's called
Purge that's a purge house keep going
lower okay look at these houses straight
up by the way bunkers right next to each
other like military keep going keep
going keep going Pat what's the
percentage of Elites that you think I'm
talking about the real Rich that have
the there people that are actually talk
our
language anyway so to our to our viewers
out there don't that wasn't uh some
weird audio so if that's just their syan
language goes back thousands of years
guys don't worry
about that just said that they're going
to go buy a doomsday prepper outfit
right there Vinnie but you know why you
can't do it in Florida here we can't buy
one in Florida the G aquafer is in the
way it's because we're basically like a
few feet above water if we go any lower
here we'll be swimming boom you're
hitting the water anyways okay is there
any story you really really want to
cover before we wrap up Tom did you have
anything you did you want to talk about
the jobs report
or do we do we cover it almost I think
we kind of covered economy when more
data comes out in a week let's uh pick
up then okay tomorrow couple things guys
tonight I'm going to be at the Tim poool
event in Miami okay they got an event
going on will be will be there tomorrow
Tim poool and Jimmy door will be here oh
on a podcast bra what time are we doing
it tomorrow is it is it 800 a.m. 7 9:
a.m. 9 why can't we do it at 7:00 a.m. I
mean Saturday morning you know what 4:
a.m. let's just say the .m tomorrow
Jimmy door and Tim pool it should make
for exciting podcast and tomorrow we
don't have an end time so we may go over
2 hours we may go 3 hours tomorrow I
don't know what we're going to go but
depends on what we'll do tomorrow
tomorrow night I'll be here and I'll be
in Miami and then next we've got a bunch
of things going on gank and then unless
if you guys got I just I just one more
time for my my uh I'm going to be in the
Tampa Improv October 18th for one show 7
p.m. the tickets are at improv tampa.com
if Rob can put it on there and uh our
friend Mike uh his birthday is today so
I want to say happy birthday to
Mike m m mie mik mik
in OJ OJ mik out happy birthday go watch
this man be funny please I'm it's going
to be I'm talking about everything and
making fun of every and Tom's comedy
special coming out when next month Tom's
opening for me okay Tom's open support
support go to Tampa Improv and support
Vinnie Vinnie your local have a great
weekend take care bye- bye
bye-bye